Speaker 1: Well, my friends, inflation has
come in and it has come in low. And if we
want to participate in this ridiculous
game wherein we say, well, if inflation
going up was Joe Biden's fault, then inflation
coming down must be credited to Joe Biden. Now,
you and I and many of the people that are in
our audience kind of prefer to operate more in
the real world where we don't play these political
games with gas prices and with inflation. So let's
not play them. Let's just look at the data and
understand that inflation is a global phenomenon.
And we're going to look at global numbers and
we're going to punch the microphone, as I often
do when I get excited. And we'll hopefully have an
understanding of the fact that this is something
that shouldn't really surprise us because it's
been the most likely trajectory for a while,
although in general we are not particularly
good as humans at making economic predictions.
Speaker 2: It did seem.
Speaker 1: As though inflation
peaked some months ago and it would be lower by
the end of the year and indeed it is. So let's
start with the data. CNBC reporting consumer
prices rose less than expected in November,
up 7.1% from a year ago. The Consumer Price
Index rose just 0.1% from the previous month,
increased 7.1% from a year ago, compared with
respective estimates of 0.3 and 7.3% core CPI. The
Consumer Price Index rose 0.2% on the month and
6% on an annual basis, compared with respective
estimates of 0.3% and 6.1%. Stocks soared. The
Dow is, as of right now, up about 400 points.
Inflation adjusted average hourly earnings for
workers rose 0.5% for the month, though they were
still down 1.9% from a year ago. Now, whenever we
do these numbers, there is confusion. David, wait.
Are prices up or are they down? What
does it mean? But if prices rose,
how are they down? Remember that there are two
components to this. What happened last month and
how does adding the data from last month change
the last 12 months of inflation? So remember,
we want a little bit of inflation. We have an
economy. And I know that this gets into. Well,
do we really buy into this traditional
economic stuff? And I get that. I get that. But
the sort of standard view is you want a little bit
of inflation, a little bit of inflation is good.
Why? If you have a ton of inflation, things
become unaffordable. So people stop buying,
which hurts businesses, so they lay people off
and then those people have no money to buy stuff
and it's bad for the economy. That's too much
inflation. If you have deflation, it might sound
good. You might say, sir, ma'am, cheaper stuff is
good. Deflation sounds good. No, it's not good for
the economy. Why? If you expect prices to continue
declining, if you're looking at a car. Right,
an electric vehicle, for example, and you expect
because we're in a deflationary situation,
that if you wait six months, the prices will be
lower. You wouldn't buy the car. That's bad for
the businesses. The employees at the electric car
businesses get laid off because nobody's buying
cars because you expect prices to go down. So
the idea is a little bit of inflation creates an
incentive to buy now rather than later. It's not
so much that things become unaffordable, and that
is where economic growth comes from now. Believe
me, I'll be the first to tell you those sort of
completely rational actor. Economic analyzes lack
a very real component. I am with you, but those
are the oranges, for lack of a better term, of
why a little bit of inflation is good. Getting
us back to the numbers. There was a little bit of
inflation last month, but compared to November of
21, it was lower. So when we replace in the one
year inflation number, the November 21 number with
the November 22 number, year over year, inflation
is lower. Okay. So that's that. Dow surges 400
points as investors cheer the light inflation
report. You know, I don't put a lot of stock in
these types of headlines. I think it's important
to remember that, you know, to some degree.
This has been predicted for months. So if
markets were completely efficient and rational,
this this new data would have already been
priced in. It doesn't really make sense that
the Dow pops because the data was what it is. But
the expectation on paper was of slightly higher
inflation and it came in lower. Okay. If you're
in the market, it's a good day. And as many of you
know, much of the return in the markets happens
on just ten days out of the year. Today may be
one of those days. Lastly, remember that inflation
is a global phenomenon. And when you look at the
inflation rates, these this is data from October
in some countries and November in some you see
that among wealthier and larger nations, nations
that are part of this list. We're looking at the
trading economics outcome list. You see that the
U.S. is sort of like right in the middle now with
year over year inflation at 7.1%, down from the
high eights. And you see that, for example, in
Italy and in the U.K., inflation is significantly
higher, whereas in Brazil and France and Singapore
and Spain, inflation is lower than in the U.S.,
has very little to do with the Joe Biden global
phenomenon. U.S. sort of like right in the
middle there. So this is overall, I believe,
a good thing. Inflation has been too high. It has
been a strain on American budgets and hopefully
this continues and we can get down again. We're
just we're not good at this, but it would be nice
to continue seeing the year over year numbers
tick down over the next six months where maybe
we can get to like the low fives, high fours
by summertime. And that would be historically
much more pleasant, I think is the word that I
would use. So that's the latest on inflation.